[Musique]
j'ai besoin de savoir ce qui m'est
arrivé
[Musique]
nous comptons un membre de plus dans le
groupe les amis tu souhaites peut-être
te présenter Madison
[Musique]
soit la bienvenue dans ce groupe de
parole et de soutien cosmortel
est-ce que tu veux nous en dire un peu
plus sur toi ou bien comment est-ce que
tu es morte
[Musique]
la police a officiellement ouvert une
enquête pour disparition inquiétante
elle s'appelle comment déjà mag
GIE
personne ne t'entend
regarde-moi Nicole les vivants ne voient
pas rien ne change jamais ici la boucle
se répète à l'infini si tu essayes de
sortir du lycée tu te retrouves là où tu
as clamsé
il paraît qu'on a trouvé une immense
flaque de sang dans le placard
d'entretien
tu devrais pas regarder ça je sais pas
qui m'a tué stop stop
je te prierai de bien vouloir lever la
main
[Musique]
j'ai besoin de savoir ce qui m'est
arrivé
[Musique]
faire leur travail attendez c'est moi ou
bien l'intrigue
tu as mourir il y a des gens qui ont
besoin de moi
s'il te plaît
[Musique]
si seulement il pouvait savoir que je
suis près de lui
toi tu sais quelque chose
tu as fait du mal à ma fille
n'apprécie pas forcément les réponses à
toutes les questions
c'est peut-être pas une mauvaise chose
que tu te rappelles pas
j'ai trouvé quelque chose
[Musique]
taper la désagréable en pression de
passer une éternité au lycée et bien là
c'est pas seulement une impression
[Musique]